The joe rogan experience,
you know,
like we always argue that marijuana is a mild hallucinogenic and you know,
therefore,
uh,
a safer and fun or alternative to being drunk and necessarily or blah,
blah,
blah.
As Louis Armstrong said,
what it's worth,
it's worth a hundred assistants,
uh,
worth a hundred assistance.
Yeah.
When you said eight,
he said,
I don't know.
Oh No.
He would have said it's better than a hundred whiskeys.
Sorry.
He said he always considered it a friend and assistant.
Oh,
that's funny.
Which I thought was really funny,
but,
but psychedelics are like,
if you say,
if you took psychedelics,
uh,
people go,
you know,
you're a drug addict.
Well,
if you smoke weed,
you're a pothead.
You know what I am,
I am as well.
But what I found out that you were,
uh,
I thought,
when,
uh,
I found out that you were the one who actually did you introduce Doug Benson to
marijuana?
That's the legend.
If you saw that Werner Herzog movie,
uh,
it's written on one of the cave walls.
There's this,
there's a Petroglyph of Doug and I stylized.
Of course,
you can't hardly recognize it.
So you can see my glasses.
It's a from hundreds of years ago.
And Doug and I were in San Diego at the Pacific Beach Improv.
If you remember that one.
No,
I don't.
Well here was this 58,
um,
we had just finished doing a roast at the friars [inaudible] we're playing San
Diego and he claims that he had smoked before,
but knock on high,
you know what I mean?
Like he'd had some,
so cause a lot of times,
you know,
you have to get high a few times before it kicks in.
Uh,
and then I brought a bunch of weed and,
and I remember what I remember is the Condo was near the beach and we were just
fucking doofuses and you know,
we would just go to the beach every day you get high.
And then when we weren't at the beach,
we would watch MTVs beach party.
Oh my God.
I remember him laying on the couch laughing hysterically at one point and
kicking his legs in the air.
And I was like,
let's go get this tacos.
And he was like,
dude,
you know,
and like it was just that stupid of that weekend.
We,
let's fucking,
and then at night we'd go desats we're working at the Improv.
And,
uh,
he claims that was where he started.
And I guess the carefree lifestyle that we were living that week seduced him so
hard because if it's beguiling poetry that he realized he as an independent
soul,
he could finally take control of his own destiny.
But I had a kid say to me once where I was on the road and like Addison,
Texas or something and that the guy was working with a nice fellow and he would
go out and you buy it like peanut that I ran like cereal that you'd see on TV
and stuff,
which made me laugh cause I'm from San Francisco,
you know,
and I'm like,
he would come back with like what a shopping lists you'd see on television,
like wonder bread and,
and he's a nice fellow.
Uh,
and he would,
he would run and whatnot.
And I was late.
I remember what year it was.
It was,
I was watching the needed hill hearings on TV and that was a Raiders game that
weekend or niners game and there was a fire in the East Bay and you can see the
fire [inaudible] was 90 90 91 somewhere in there,
laying on the couch,
smoking weed,
and he goes,
you're going to smoke pot all fucking day proofs.
And I go,
let me ask you something.
Whatever his name was,
Danny,
again,
let me ask you something.
Who kills every night and you,
you do
you have your program?
Well people,
his board too.
I was trapped in the condo.
There was no,
it was one of those ones that wasn't near anything.
I think a waffle house or something.
But if you wanted it to be tactical about like a comics time creating,
it's all day and it's all day watching TV and you're,
you could be scanning for something that inspires you enough to be your next
closing bit.
So you're actually working.
So even when you're lounging,
you're working.
I think of Stephanie and Dad,
I man,
Dad,
and if I wake up in the middle of the night,
I go,
I need to do the thing tomorrow.
I have to think of this.
And then I think of it and you know,
I would argue that the creative process,
you can manufacture it.
Yes.
But it works better if you down.
Yeah.
It's a,
everybody goes dry.
Sometimes you get to drive it.
Also working hard makes you not go dry.
That's true too.
It's a muscle.
Yeah.
I think the,
the,
there's like a vibe that you get into when you're really writing a lot and that
vibe sort of like,
it just,
it,
it becomes like a part of your consciousness and then the,
the more you feed it and the more you do it,
I think that's what the thing with everything,
every,
everything that a person does,
whether it's an art form or a musical instrument,
and if it isn't an art form,
it's not important Joe,
but go on.
True.
It is true.
Yeah.
The idea of the creative process is something that's always been so fascinating
to me.
And like,
I love listening to how other people do it.
And especially comics,
like some of them are just fucking,
they just sit down and put in the time.
They just put in the hours and some of them just sit around and watch things all
day and scratch their head and look at the Internet and just poke around and
prod,
you know,
and then some of them,
they just,
uh,
they just write in and stand up for them.
Some people write in blog form,
don't you love when you think a joke springs fully formed from your breast and
you haven't thought of it.
It just comes out and you do it and it's perfect and you go,
uh,
like people always say,
you know,
whatever,
the Beatles,
um,
how did you write that song?
And sometimes they'll go,
honestly,
I sat down and it,
you know what I mean?
I had it,
I didn't write it.
I,
yeah,
came out and like every once in a while there'll be a joke that you think of and
it's just the right one.
And it made it not be like genius or anything.
It's just that feeling of when it um,
that your,
that your subconscious pushed it out and you weren't fucking with it in any way
and therefore it's,
perfection is different than something you worked on.
Yeah.
There's this weird thing of,
again it goes back to the ego,
this weird thing of what whoever the fuck you think of yourself as,
you know,
this self defining sort of image that,
you put up as like sort of a wall for tuck very much.
Yeah.
And when you want to take credit for the idea,
what would,
the way creativity comes,
it comes when you're in the state of like,
like open when you're open to receive it.
When you're really thinking about things like completely all your resources are
on the thing.
Not about the bullshit,
not about like trying to craft an image on stage or trying to formulate
something that you think is going to make the back of the room laugh and of that
it's all coming from like a true openness.
And then they did.
It just comes like as you,
sometimes it's just like moments,
you know,
these,
these bursts of ideas will come to you and they are just gifts from the
university and they hit you like waves and you can't even write them down quick
enough and you're giggling while you're writing on it.
Yeah.
And it's like a gift.
It's like a gift for thinking the right way or a gift for approaching it with
the correct respect.
Like realizing that you are the lucky one to be able to tune into this.
It's not that you're this fabulous person who you know is so awesome because you
say funny shit.
No,
you're the lucky one that has found this ability to tune into these ideas and
you should praise these ideas and honor these ideas.
It's true.
I think just pushing yourself to think of something.
I repeat myself a million times,
but to think of something new when you're riffing.
Yeah.
It's how I hard.
That's really hard.
Like on the podcast,
I,
uh,
I'll just attempt things sometimes that aren't that funny,
but I'm like trying to,
you know,
like disconnect.
So that you're,
you're kind of trying to automatic,
right?
If you can,
you're a fucking human being.